my name is Tim I had the greatest
parents ever rise and shine take your
kid to work day
really it was just the three of us the
Templeton's life was perfect until that
one fateful day yeah meet your new baby
[Music]
he wears a suit he's like a little man
he carries a briefcase there's no one
else things that's oh I don't know a
little freaky
will you carry lamb-lamb around until
you were like this is not about
lamb-lamb trust me one day you're gonna
love him with all of your heart never
[Music]
how the usual procedures sleep
deprivation hunger strikes
they're very disoriented but I think the
kid might be on to me poop duty I've got
a deal with the ki D you can talk uh
googoo gaga
no you can really doc fine I can talk
now let's see if you can listen get me a
double espresso and see if there's
someplace around here with decent sushi
I'd kill for a spicy tuna roll right
about now get yourself a little
something
who are you let's just say I'm the boss
just wait till mom and dad find out
about this
power nap uh you were saying
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is this the lost village this is clue I
wouldn't touch that if I were you well
now you said that all I want to do is
touch it oh um guys who are they
yeah it must be great to be Batman
thank you I'm blushing super are double
the mass imagine he's going home right
now party the night away surrounded my
friend and lady activewear models hey
computer I'm home master Bruce your
greatest fear is snakes nan Stiles new
it's being a part of a family again
no now it's snake Klaus because you put
that idea in my head sir you need to
take responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising the young orphan you
adopt me I thought I was being sarcastic
oh my god love is cancer just a little
site
I own idea
it's better I can only look you in the
eyes right now greatest enemies
Superman is my greatest enemy Superman
it's not a bad guy did I say that I
don't currently have a bad guy I am
fighting a few different people I like
to fight around hi Barbara Gordon new
police commissioner
it's my dream the police force to team
up with Batman what wouldn't that be
better I hate everything you just said
initialize master villain we did it
pretty cool huh why did you build this
thing with only one seed just last check
I only had one bud let's go defeat the
Joker we're going on a family trip I can
wear my costumes here well luckily for
us you left your costume bag oh no under
your clothes that's perfect
welcome to snow mountain where sheep
live in harmony but the dog who was bred
to guide them sees you dream comes in
your face yes
did you see that would rather rock and
roll
I like tight death I've decided to
become a musician you're not gonna be a
musician boney you're gonna be a guard
get used to it
but when inspiration falls from the sky
it any advice for up-and-coming
musicians never stop even when your dad
says stop he'll make his dream a reality
Bodhi isn't you is looking for his own
paradise what's this go to the city find
that passion I love you son from the
co-director of Toy Story 2 what bring
him to me we get in we get snow mountain
can we get a red cord to go with the red
phone come on next year this is fate
mister scatter kid came to rock and roll
park found a band in need of a guitar
player I think you ought to go up and
meet ask him to give you some guitar
lessons okay
I'll just that was a nutter follow your
passion I was so sure this was the band
you're gonna find one it doesn't just
happen overnight
mister scatter go sets will never stop
nothing will ever make me Oh
discover your power scour every square
inch of the city and find it my family's
in danger I need to go
Otis
it's the answer the question of my life
- closes
huh completely paralyzed does he except
for my mouth my mouth is what I'm a
finger Rock dog hey turn around show me
what you got you a pal pal uh can I take
it up a notch oh my god Wow take a mile
let me take a heist music
[Music]
[Music]
it's some kind of monster
wait that's not a mobster that's a man
wearing shoulder pads there's only one
super villain whose fashion sense is
quite dead dating free Balthazar
Bret I want every agent of the scene
immediately
hey mr. C are closing fast guests wait
why what did you call us
Brucie you know GRU and Lucy Bush
together Brucie ha ha I like it but not
a lot I don't like it getting away
that's when you think
get the ready boy
Oh
hello goo haha what about that Wow oh
yeah this is not over
[Music]
ah to you happy birthday dear day
and happy birthday who's bad
you